it is extraordinary every time we head
out to take a look at what's going on we
see yet another breach and more water
flooding areas and people's homes just
before we came to you a tractor went
right past loaded with people's
belongings there seems to be a departure
going on from a village nearby right now
because there must be a warning that yet
another flood barrier has been breached
what little there is in this part of the
world
you can probably see behind me there's a
thatched roof that's the all you can see
of the house in the water here people
have resorted to living in tents on the
sides of roads that's the people that
have the tents overnight we've heard
from the military that are carrying out
a rescue operation that they have
rescued 50 000 people that's no mean
feat when you consider they can only
take 18 people on a boat or 25 in a
helicopter but when you consider more
than 30 million people are affected it's
just scratching the surface we joined a
rescue mission yesterday on a boat it
took us three hours to rescue around 18
people five children
seven women
a number of men and you know a lot of
people didn't want to come on the boat
they were terrified either of the water
and of drowning or of leaving their
homes and their belongings they're in an
extraordinary predicament here but i
really can't begin to tell you just how
much water there is three hours on a
boat to get to one family alone